Keanu Reeves is off and running on a  third excellent adventure so moving and  funny and I love those characters our  heroes are in New Orleans it looks like  that time-traveling phone booth is back  hey it's a real cool story for the guys  on Monday Alex winter bill posted day  one see you on the other side and  remember to be excellent be excellent be  excellent yes that's the band shirt by  the way  one fan said it all please be good  please be good please be good dude Alex  promises it will be the idea of  revisiting them when they're adults with  kids and families and seeing how they've  changed just seemed like right for  comedy the guys were anything but grown  up on our 1991 visit to the set of Bill  and Ted's second movie what we do know  is that the Grim Reaper will be back as  well as historical figures like Gandhi  and the Indian Sacagawea Bill and Ted  three face the music  villains head three maybe  [Music]